from the uh dope as usual podcast yes
sir now do you go by Thomas Yola
dopasiola what is your um I I introduce
myself as Thomas to everybody okay but
people call me anything man people call
me a bunch of different things so I man
it's crazy because I was not really hip
to
like the weed YouTube world it's there
until recently oh really very recently
oh yeah and I'm like world listen I'm
pretty heavily involved in the weed [__]
you know so like it was just kind of
I've been to like a lot of seshes and
stuff and I feel like I've met a lot of
people but I wasn't very hip until
recently Travis Thompson came on our
show and he came right after he left
your thing
and uh and he should like he was like
dude this dude just got me high as [__]
I try not to come too high though just
because I knew he was coming and it was
crazy because I was like oh [__] and
then I followed your guys's podcast page
that day
and then
you guys did Jeezy and it and like your
[__] just kept popping up and then I
just went on a [__] Deep dive because
I really like the way your guys's
podcast is presented the way it looks is
your boy Marty handle all that yeah
Mario Myanmar do everything he's a beast
dude he's awesome
um but it's a great show like I really
like went on like a
a [__] Bender like just watching some
of your stories thank you and uh I was
like damn this dude's [__] got a sick
life
yeah I don't think about it that way a
lot often but if I do that shit's wild
so for I mean you're obviously you're
from Merced right Merced California
shout out to GB we had GB on the show
before yeah shout out to GB just got the
Merced like a philanthropist award from
the city two days he's a great guy bro
he was just recording here last week uh
sweet guy man
um we also had another kid from Merced
on the show the 16 year old kid I met at
little Russell's house
yeah he's a rapper from Merced with
grads glasses he's like the next kid
he's incredible so I've I met him at the
Russell's house oh [__] and I was like
so mesmerized by his freestyle or
whatever he did on stage at the
Russell's house I was like bro you got
to come to LA and rap on my show really
him and his dad came on a school day on
a school day it was [__] sad that's
awesome
um and I'm actually on the radio in
uh
and it's not okay Modesto Modesto no
yeah what's the station it's like hot I
think hot 1047. I think that's the
station I'm on hot 104 or 105 now I'm on
the Hip Hops or whatever the Rhythm oh
[__] yeah yeah that's the only uh that's
the only Outlet we have in town is the
radio man yeah shout out to Merced man
Merced dude that's the most the drive
through anyone it's a drive-through city
is it it is why you got you need drugs
that's the spot you stop on the way to
La where's they got cookies there right
in the lemonade or is it just is there
and none of that I'm talking about
dispensary wise honestly no I think
there is I think there's I think there's
a cookies there I've never been to a
dispensary in my town ever why would you
well I just
I've just never been it's it popped up
in the last three or four years and
honestly I don't really go a lot of
dispensaries here I mean neither do I
yeah like all the weed I get is free so
I just I like to I get that much free
weed from people every day but I just
buy there's just certain weeds I buy
what is your go-to like strain like
you're you prefer it's non-existent
right now but the gaseous OG's on the
planet is all I want to smoke sure OG
guys every day in my sleep but I can't
find it well it's kind of crazy because
like oh geez have kind of died out right
where it was kind of like what eight or
nine years ago every rapper was off the
OG I would buy a pound every month and
I'd smoke it throughout the month right
and I was happy and then I got a pound
and went what is this [__] Fool's
Gold yeah get burned with that tastes
like sulfur you got me and then I got
another two packs and I went are you
[__] kidding me I just wasting my
money I'm not like almost like the
Exotics have just taken over to the
point where it's like in candy yeah it's
like anything candy takes over this I
bought a pea this is lemon I've been
smoking this lemon and it's so fire so
you're still buying uh you're still
buying I mean you as much free weed as
you get oh I I don't want to hurt
anyone's feelings but I will try your
weed and I give it to all my homies
because then they don't got to buy weed
they don't gotta do [__] Cyrus how much
weed do I give you every [__] week
so much weed and I'm like
first of all a lot of the [__] is
whatever right yeah
yeah it comes a cool bag I just feel bad
like I have two Zips here like full here
take some I'm not gonna smoke that for
at least two weeks yeah you know what I
mean for sure yeah or my sister my dad
my dad is my dad's in town right now I
just lace him I'm like take all this
[__] let's be hyped oh yeah like uh
Jardine in Las Vegas they give me like
store credit every month so I'll go to
Vegas and I'll just be like Dad what do
you want because they sponsor a park
yeah they just hit us up they're great
guys I was wondering who I was wondering
if I moved out of Vegas yeah who are you
talking to uh Mario's handling that that
they're great guys yeah cool [__] with
them I've never been to any of this I've
only been to pardine is the one it's
like you walk in and it's like the it's
like the Rolls Royce of dispensaries
they have their own scent it's like a
signature scent they got their own shoes
they they do they drop their own feelers
they're all set no I swear to God but
you can buy bored me like yo what do we
need
we need people to smell like us like
what the [__] so good we had the candles
but we ran out of them because you you
like the candy and now it smells like
Jardine that's amazing bro do they grow
there too at the spot no they're
strictly they do not just yeah they're
strictly retail because I feel like a
lot of people who try to go full
vertical they end up [__] at a
business or or just never that great
yeah the overturn of employees and goes
I don't care about this crop I guess I'm
gonna get paid today yeah that's a lot
so they're strictly retail yeah and then
they're doing like a they've got some
big plans I can't see what they're doing
but they got some big planes it's Vegas
you know yeah um